so I Claire Hughes being the properly
appointed acting returning officer for
the UK parliamentary election for the
Forest of Dean constituency on the 7th
of may 2015 do hereby declare that the
number of votes cast for each candidate
at this election is as follows Chris
Coleman 2630 James Greenwood 2703 mark
harper 23 thousand 191 Steve Perry home
12,000 204 and Steve Stanberry 8790 to
know ballot papers were rejected for 12
the fish'll mark 64 were rejected for
voting for more than one candidate three
were rejected by writing or mark by
which the voter could be identified and
117 were rejected for unmarked or void
for uncertainty and there was a total
number of votes cast a 49 phase and 704
congratulations mark
um ladies and gentlemen I'll be as brief
as I can given I know you've all been
working extremely hard first of all I'd
like to thank the returning officer and
her staff I know having walked around
the room how long you've been here and
and how how much efforts been gone into
this and I think you probably want to go
to bed and I'd also thank the police for
the work that they've done I'd also like
to thank my campaign team those that
have worked over the years those that
work for me my parliamentary office and
those that worked incredibly hard
through this campaign and at this count
I would also like to thank the other
candidates and I want to say something
that's not always very popular but I
think anyone who stands for elected
office who's prepared to put themselves
out there and subject themselves to the
electorate deserves credit and I don't
think it's helpful if politicians join
in the denigration that we sometimes get
those of us in public life from the
media and others not everyone is
prepared to put themselves forward to
give the electorate a choice so I thank
all those that made this a contest but
most of all I'd like to thank that the
people of the forest of dean for once
again putting their trust in me to be
there member of parliament for the
forthcoming Parliament I'm very pleased
with the campaign that we ran here in
the forest of dean I think it was a very
positive campaign focused on the issues
and not on the other candidates I think
we run a very positive campaign
nationally the very clear issue that
came through for me on the doorstep was
I think the public do want us to finish
the job we started five years ago about
putting the economy right we haven't
seen all the results from across the
country but I am hopeful that in the
next few hours the Prime Minister will
be able to continue
work over the next parliament and I look
forward to working with him in whatever
capacity he determines to put the people
of the forest of dean first and to do
what I can to serve them and to serve
our country thank you very much indeed